hello everyone a lot of you probably
heard of Francois and Rosanna Khan but
most of you know him by the name of Phil
adore and it's an interesting story how
he got the name the person responsible
is actually was actually the the Emperor
of France Louisa 13th because one day
the Emperor's court musician died and
the Emperor said bring me another
musician and they brought him Philidor
his grandfather and the Emperor was so
impressed with his playing style he said
something like and thus I have my silly
daughter again because his playing style
reminded him of the famous Italian
musician - Vittorio and okay the
grandfather got really fond of this name
and he decided to is the French version
of the name Theodore - his family name
so when young Francois Andre Daniken was
born he was immediately called Phil
adored by everyone especially his father
always causing nothing but Philidor so
yeah
fun story and Philidor was actually a
great musician himself but in those days
you could actually make a lot more money
by being great chess player than by
being a great musician and Philidor was
actually taught how to play chess by
none other than france want one delle
God and he was considered to be the
greatest chess player in the world
somewhere around 1730
I'm sure you've all heard of legals made
you know when you captured the knight in
the center capture the pawn in the
center with your nice sacrificer queen
and then checkmate your opponent very
nice mate so yeah I mean philidor's
ideas were all about the center of the
board and all about the position of the
points he considered points to be the
soul of chess and nothing could be done
without them so this is a game silver
played against an unknown player but you
know the moves he played are extremely
good for for when this game was played
it was in 1790 so Philidor is white and
he plays efore we have E 5 and Philidor
places the King's gambit because you
know this is this is what he's all about
he once said I'd like to capture the s
pawn so he took four d4 and control the
center with his pawns we have it
captures on f4 and now Knight to f3
we have g5 Bishop to c4
of the g7 and now h4 you know asking
black to push g4 or tickets run on h4
but black plays h6 and we have D for now
d6 and here to replace a brilliant move
especially since this was played in 1790
he plays c3 and he completely nullify
this dark square bishop and prepares a
battery with Queen to b3 and Bishop to
c4 to hit f7
so we have c6 black peppers b5 and so
there of course plays Queen to b3 not
stopping d5 and also threatening to
capture on f7 we have Queen to e7 and
the Sodor castles so we have nice to d7
and now so the replace H gets worse on
g5 we have h captures on g5 and now this
is a beautiful example of why you
shouldn't leave your king in the center
of the board unmoved them Philidor plays
nice capture some g5 sacrificing a whole
night and it's not that easy to decline
this sacrifice as well this f7 square is
attacked three times now so people is
another Queen Kathryn g5 and we have
been captured on f7 and the best move
for black here is king to d8 but his
opponent actually plays King to f8 so we
have king to f8 and a fold or plays
Bishop to f4 attacking the Queen and his
opponent plays Queen to h4 and in this
position Philidor actually has a force
made in four moves so feel free to find
it it's it's quite a lovely checkmate
okay those of you who pause the video
and try to find it I congratulate you
for your efforts and those of you who
haven't a Philidor plays Bishop captures
and d6 would check we have nice to e7
only move now we have Bishop to g6 with
a discovered check from the rook and the
King can over the King has no squares to
go to the Queen is slicing this way the
bishop is slicing this way so only move
is the block block of the rook with a
beast
and after Bishop to f6 he seemed to
place between the f7 with checkmate so
yeah a beautiful game where Philidor and
as you can see you can try and look a
look at our philidor's games that you
always see if he has the white pieces
you always see a pawn on d4 and the pawn
on e4 because yeah it was he was one of
the earliest earliest people to to say
that you know you should control the
center to win the game which was later
completely put in action by William
shinies well yeah I mean in 1790 there
wasn't really any any knowledge of
positional chest so this was a quite an
accomplishment and Philidor was the
strongest player in the world
taking that title from Sardella gaul so
yeah that's this short video about
Philidor and the nice story about how he
got his family name I do hope you
enjoyed it and I would like to thank Rae
Fowler
thank you for a contribution to my
channel I really appreciate it and
that's it guys as usual you can trip to
all my previous videos here and I'll see
you soon